foreign
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Planet
coaster and welcome back to aerobats of
Arabia today I'm teasing you guys with
more scenery building and no more
coaster building I know some of you guys
have commented in the last episode that
I just keep on doing things that are
completely off topic but in my defense I
really want this whole themed area to be
coherent and to fit very well with the
coasters themselves so I'm continuously
trying to come up with this entire area
while I'm also finishing the coaster
layouts so every now and then that means
I'll just be doing things that are
seemingly outside of The Coasters
themselves but I think are pretty
important to this whole theme Bland and
today's episode is no difference I'm not
going to be adding much to The Coasters
themselves but this is an area which I
think is very important to finishing the
overall look of the later stages of the
layouts as well as the front of the
station building because the buildings
that I'm going to be work talking only
this episode starting off with the
building for this Carousel over here are
going to finish the square in front of
the station building
um and so I think it's one of the most
important areas in this whole land and
one where I'm going to try and combine
many different sight lines and some of
the most iconic structures to create
this one space where hopefully people
will have to end up of course because
you need to get here to actually enter
the ride's queue line but at the same
time be like oh wow this is really the
Thematic center point of this whole
theme to land so it's a it's a pretty
high bar I'm setting for myself there I
suppose but that's that's the idea of
this whole square plus at the same time
I'm trying to create an area where these
coasters can wind their way into a dark
ride section which is going to be the
final stage of the layouts and getting
out of the Dark Ride section at the
start of the layout was relatively easy
because I was able to hide most of that
transition from the view of people on
the paths but for this area I think it's
not going to be that easy because we
have these coasters going into a
building in full view of this this
Square in front of them and yeah I'm
definitely going to have to work a bit
on coming up with a way to make them
enter a building that doesn't seem too
weird and too out of place and just
drags you out of your immersion of the
themed land at this point
but starting off we have the carousel
here and the reason I built this thing
was partly because I wanted to have a
centerpiece to look at from the
direction of the waterfronts so when you
walk from the Waterfront towards this
area we have one straight section of
path between some of the buildings with
also an archway Gallery Crossing it and
then in an exactly symmetrical point of
view we have this Carousel in the
distance and also if you come from the
other paths you can see it along with
the station building in the distance so
I wanted to make sure it kind of fit in
there as well
um so all that to say I would consider
this thing a little mini weenie it's not
really their focal point of the whole
themed area that's definitely the
station building but from some
perspectives it is definitely the focal
point or or trying to work in
conjunction with the the station
building so this is a pretty important
building for me and it's it's one that's
pretty fun to work on as well I have to
say because for this Carousel I wanted
to come up with something that fit into
the mamluk style architecture of Egypt
that I've been working on in the last
episode but at the same time I did not
make it too big or grandiose and still
keep an open feeling and so I was kind
of browsing through all kinds of
buildings in Egypt and the region to to
see what kind of architecture would work
for a flat right like this speaking of
which I ended up choosing the carousel
because it's one of the few flat rides
with a small footprint most of the most
of the flat rides in this game just end
up having such a huge footprint that it
wouldn't be doable to place it anywhere
near this area or it would just end up
way too huge but this thing is small
enough I think to fit into a nice
Pavilion
um so yeah I was looking for a while uh
for what kind of buildings would fit for
this purpose and eventually I ended up
with this design that's kind of inspired
by um what I believe is called a sabil
I'm not sure how accurate my
pronunciation is there but a water
dispensing Fountain which typically have
some kind of Pavilion design you can
find them in the Ottoman Empire and well
the countries that are previously the
Ottoman Empire but also in mamluk style
architecture and
um in Egypt you can commonly find them
as far as I can see in the inner
Courtyards of many musks where they have
a large Courtyard surrounded by
different arches and also one of these
Pavilions so
um yeah that's the kind of architecture
I figured would work out very well for
this purpose and from an in-game
building perspective it's pretty easy
and fun to do as well but it results in
a pretty cool looking building because
you can just use the Dome technique the
age-old technique which in this case is
especially handy I think because I'm
making use of double pillars behind all
of these arches so I don't have to worry
too much about these pillars exactly
matching up because usually the
challenge with the Dome technique is
making sure that your building is not
just exactly in the middle of whatever
you're trying to create a dome or a
round Pavilion shape building around but
also making sure that once you rotate
that thing around everything matches up
so you could very well imagine that with
this kind of arch building once you
start copying those things around you
might realize that your last section is
only the length of half an arch and then
the whole thing falls apart you know
everything has to fit together perfectly
but that's something that you can kind
of test along the way and it's extra
easy if you have two pillars like this
because you don't have to worry too much
about the last parts that you rotate
around that kind of have to connect
everything together that they won't
match up in some way so all things
considered it's a pretty fun Endeavor
and then we get to the actually slightly
more challenging part which is the roof
here where I do want to try and make a
smooth a roof as possible and thankfully
I have the rest of the building to guide
me so whenever you do a pavilion like
this whenever you build something like
this I would generally recommend because
this building has hard edges to do the
building itself first and then do the
roof because in this case I could use
the building as a guideline start off
from the corners of the walls and the
Arches and use that to shape out the
roof and make sure that it actually fits
and then you just rotate around and make
sure it's all good and just continuously
do that rotation trick along the way to
see whether you're you're still on the
right track because if you start adding
detailing and then you do the Dome
technique and you rotate the thing
around and it turns out that things
aren't exactly matching uh then you're
kind of screwed and it's a lot harder to
re well recover from your mistakes at
that point
um and then for the top of this building
I'm actually going the the very easy
route and just plopping down uh tmtk
Dome here and that should more or less
finish it off and then we just have one
last section to do also something to
notice is that I shifted the height of
the stucco plates on the roof a little
bit and change the colors of some of the
plates a little bit as you can see
especially from some perspectives with
certain kinds of lighting you can see
that you have lots of Stucco pieces in
there all of which aren't exactly the
same color in which don't have the exact
same placement so that helps to review a
little bit more natural as well I feel
and also it prevents Z fighting every
now and then if you have some textures
that are clipping into each other but
generally with the tmtk stucco pieces
from Hydro I believe they are you don't
have to worry too much about Z fighting
because the texture is just that simple
but especially if you use some bigger
textures or textures with more variety
you have to be very careful of not
clipping different pieces into each
other oh and what's also worth
mentioning and I just realized I didn't
mention yet but specifically this
Pavilion is inspired by the Pavilion in
the Musk madrasa
uh which is uh not the complete name of
that thing but honestly I'm not going to
even try to pronounce the whole thing of
it but it's a mosque in Cairo and that's
about all you need to know from me you
know sometimes I have to realize I'm
also you know uh not equipped to talk
about certain things I'm just a guy who
plays theme park games for fun and you
know not an architectural expert and
definitely not an expert on pronouncing
Arabian names get off my case anyway
um one thing that was going to be a
little bit more challenging for this
building is making the exit and the
entrance Parts especially because this
building is raised it is something that
I think is a good addition to this whole
area because it means that there's
finally some elevation differences one
thing that I was kind of worrying about
with this whole area is that everything
felt quite flat and you don't get a lot
of depth in your themed area if you
don't have at least some elevation
differences and those elevation
differences don't have to come from
terrain only you know of course you can
build your parks on a flat terrain but
it's always good I think if you have
certain Pathways that go up and down
buildings or hillsides or something like
that to add some depth to an area so
this building is basically fulfilling
that function for this area but that
does mean that of course this is planet
coaster and it's going to be a little
bit more difficult to do path works when
everything isn't completely straight and
when you don't want everything to look
like it's in-game default counterpart so
here I wanted to build a staircase and
kind of hide the in-game Pieces away
with lots of large pick pieces from tmtk
which I think works out quite well
especially with the Sandstone colors it
just manages to fit in with the rest of
the building because it manages to use
mostly the same kind of pieces but it is
a lot of very specific block placements
at this point to try and and make
everything fit together so it's
definitely something to think about if
you want to try these kinds of things
something that this actually reminds me
of I had already recorded this episode
prior to uploading the last one so it's
not something that changed my direction
in this episode uh but on the last video
there was a comment from somebody called
the doctor about making accessible
rooftop areas in buildings and I think
that would actually be a really good
idea and a bit of a missed opportunity
for this themed area to add more depth
to this this whole land and actually
allow people to also see the area from
different perspectives in hindsight I've
been feeling like I missed the boat on
creating an interesting queue I think
what would have been a very interesting
queue line for this ride is to make it
go up roofs of buildings and have some
bridges and archways crossing paths and
just snaking its way through the city
unfortunately that's something that I
don't see myself fitting into this area
anymore especially now that all of the
buildings already have their functions
we have The Coasters going through this
area we have a food court in some of the
buildings in the future we have this
ride in this building so it's not really
going to work out anymore
um but in the future and maybe if this
part continues if it manages not to fry
my computer already with this this first
themed land you know I'm just gonna keep
dropping very subtle hints that this
might become something bigger but I'm
definitely promising that because that's
a that's a very very big if and when
it's possible
um but if that does happen I definitely
want to try out something like that and
I'm not sure where and how that could
fit in
um but something that I've been thinking
about is that queue lines
are Sometimes good sometimes bad but
almost always hidden from View and you
know almost always have very little
interaction with the rest of the park
and I think there are some exceptions to
that rule very few though I think one of
them is the queue line for fly and
Fantasia land which isn't always the
best queue line because some parts are a
little bit messy but it snakes its way
throughout the themed area that it's in
and you can see it also from some of the
main Pathways and in a sense it is a
strategy to hide your queue line from
view because it makes people feel less
iffy about entering the queue line
because something that will make you
feel horrible on the theme park is
looking at a long long queue and then
deciding that you have to join it for
some reason I'm pretty sure the human
psyche likes that less than not knowing
what you're in for and then standing in
a queue for an hour but at the same time
I do feel it's a very missed opportunity
to not have more interaction between a
queue line and its themed land because
even if I'm thinking about good queue
lines I'm thinking about the Flying
Dutchman in the afterlink or I'm
thinking about 2
000 leaks under the sea in Tokyo
Disneyland or especially I should say A
Journey to the Center of the Earth in
Tokyo Disneyland now these are very
well-themed queues and they're very good
at what they do but they're still very
much hidden so I'm still kind of playing
in my head with the idea of making a
themed cue that makes its way through a
themed area kind of in a sense that they
almost do in Fantasia land but make it a
bit more designed into the area
but at the same time find that that
balance of not making it look horrible
for people who are outside of the queue
line we'll see in the future also
speaking of cues I managed to talk about
cues for a few minutes and not even
mention the queue that I was building in
the meantime and now the moment's
already gone
um but I just built a small queue for
the carousel which is also going to be
its own little theming area for that
area of the park because it'll just have
some foliage around it and some rock
work and it's going to add some much
needed Greenery I think to this whole
area because there are so many buildings
with gray brownish colors in this area
and the same goes for the path Works
which makes sense I think considering
the theme but I really wanted to add
some parts also where I could add more
corinery because you know on these kinds
of large plazas and buildings the only
way to do that is through Planters and
small bushes here and there
um but I wanted to have an area which
was a little bit more green so the
carousel helps me to add that as well
which I think also fits very well with
the building that I'm going to be
working on in a few minutes so over here
I am finishing off the side of the
station and this is basically using
pieces that I kind of stole from the
station building itself but at the same
time they're a little bit different so
hopefully they fit in well enough to not
make for a jarring transition but at the
same time it's not completely the same
it's also inspired by the Central Square
in Isfahan in Iran which also has a
bunch of beautiful mosques and palaces
but connecting those mosques and palaces
is a huge completely rectangular wall of
these pointed arches and
um I thought that was a really cool look
to kind of imitate here so for me it's
just one corner and not a complete
rectangular Square because I'm still
trying to fit this into my themed land
but I think it kind of works to connect
the mosque to the dark right building
because
obviously this wall of arches is also
built to hide the dark right building
and uh we're also gonna have to do some
kind of transition to the architecture
of the musk station building uh to the
part where the two coasters enter uh the
Dark Ride section which is coming up
here and at the same time I'm trying my
hardest to make it look like a row of
different buildings but as it as is very
much the case in many theme parks it is
just a single building so trying to make
as many differences in color and Heights
and Architectural Styles along this row
of facants as possible but in reality
I'm just trying to hide one big gray box
from from the view of the park and we're
definitely gonna have to have some huge
backstage area behind this as well I'm
definitely gonna have to figure out what
I'm going to do with that roof structure
but those are worries for some later
dates I think for now I'm very concerned
and just focusing on the theming of it
now the last thing to mention about this
building in the corner is that at some
point in future it's going to have to
house the exit path with a gift shop and
a photo booth not entirely sure how
that's going to work out but um it's my
plan I'm trying to house as many things
like not just the ride itself but also
the queue line and everything else Under
One Roof over here because realistically
that's what a theme park like this would
do to conserve their space now moving on
to another facade in this row of
buildings this is going to be my
solution for the entry into the dark
right section for these coasters and
it's a little bit of an odd one but it's
one that I arrived at after a bunch of
experimentation with what kind of thing
I could build and what kind of thing
would realistically make sense for this
theme and I ended up finding my
inspiration in jehal satoon Palace which
is a palace in Iran and the name
translates from Persian to English into
40 columns and the joke behind that name
well I guess it's not really a joke but
basically what the name comes from is
the fact that it's this palace with this
this interesting architecture with 20
large tall wooden pillars and that
actually stand quite far apart from each
other and hold up the roof of the
building
um and in front of the building is a
large pool and the building is in the
middle of a park so it has a really nice
green surrounding and then if you look
at the building from the other side of
the pool you'll have the reflection of
the pillars in the water and you'll see
40 pillars so I thought that was a funny
little backstory but most importantly I
think the in the architecture is very
interesting and it makes it fit into
this area and it makes it kind of fit
into what I'm trying to build as an
entrance for the dark ride here because
I needed something where the pillars
stand far away from each other because
these coaster these coaster cars are
just way too wide to fit into any kind
of theming but with this kind kind of
architecture I think it kind of works
out and these pillars these wooden
pillars had this very particular style
to them and I'm trying to emulate that a
little bit with these here just using
some small blocks to make the capitals
for these and I was experimenting a bit
with dressing it up with some foliage as
well because I am trying to hide a
little bit how simple this building
really is
but I also dragged yeah I also got some
of the the Egyptian mambuk influences
into this building as well so the the
stone is very similar in color to the
Pavilion next to it to try and make that
transition from the Persian architecture
on one side and the Egyptian mamluk
style architecture on the other side
which are wildly different things of
course but I'm trying to at least
provide a little bit of a separation
between them and trying to stick to my
theme for this whole land of
transitioning from one theme to the
other very quickly and in very small
areas but at the same time trying to
fight yeah trying to figure out how
those transitions can actually work
which reminds me of a genius comment on
my last video by Matt milbrand which was
to use colors to represent different
areas and themes within the themed land
so for example I could use a lot of red
or purple as a highlight color in many
of the buildings in the Egyptian area
and then use green to the many of the
buildings in the Persian area and then
the color could somehow communicate that
there are these differences within one
themed land that is generally A Thousand
and One Nights inspired basically which
I thought was a really cool idea I'm not
sure if and how I can fit it into this
area but it's definitely something that
I want to remember and maybe good toy
width at some point in the future
because it could make things a little
bit more recognizable because one thing
that I am a little bit concerned about
people who are interested in
architecture and are listening to my
ramblings about different kinds of
architecture to that inspired me on
different buildings they can look at
these and recognize that they are coming
from different parts of the world but
somebody with no architectural knowledge
coming into this park just for a fun day
with the family it might not see that
kind of difference and I think it would
be interesting to figure out how to make
it a little bit more obvious while still
you know not making the transitions to
jarring between different areas and I
think working with highlight colors and
making that somehow recognizable would
be a really cool way to experiment with
that so I'm definitely keeping it in
mind but it's something where I'm not
sure how exactly it's going to work out
um
and also in the meantime I started work
on the minarets which I wanted to place
next to the Carousel Building which kind
of makes it look like a mini Mosque of
sorts I just figured that I needed
something with a little bit more height
next to this building to counteract the
the visual weight of the giant Dome and
minarets on the other side of the square
and also make this really a finishing a
center point on this side of the area so
I decided to build a mum look inspired
minarets and this is one that is very
much inspired by just all the minarets
that you can find in Cairo not a
particular one but it has the style of
basically all of them as they typically
consist of three tiers that are
separated by balconies and each tier
will have its own distinct style and
often even shape which is quite
different from minarets for example in
ottoman architecture so in this case I
started off with a square base with a
large Square balcony and supported by
lots of detailing and then we go into
this round Tower base where I still put
some of the same detailing and the same
kind of balcony but obviously everything
has a different shape and then finally
we're going to move over to the top
where we have the final balcony as well
as a little Spire roof structure that
should finish the whole minaret
and that brings me to my last thing that
I kind of wanted to talk about in this
video which is a little bit of a
different topic
um uh a good friend of mine meno left
some constructive criticism on my
Discord which I haven't replied yet on
the Discord but I definitely read and
took the heart and it kind of made me
reflect on a lot of things because he
had some very good points to point out
about the last episode one of which was
that the archway to the food court could
use some improvements and that is the
archway to the food court next to the
Moroccan building but also the large art
way Archway to the food court on this
side of the square next to the the
Egyptian building with the red Dome
because both of them aren't really
fitting in with the style of the rest of
this area especially the one next to the
Moroccan building makes the transition a
little bit jarring and also the
lettering is is honestly pretty bad and
I definitely agree I could do better on
that front that said
um he also commented about how the
Egyptian building with the red dome in a
sense I I feel like what he was trying
to say is that it feels a little bit
orientalist which I think is very fair
uh it's definitely a kind of European
inspired Dome and one that you wouldn't
really find in Egyptian architecture
um but I think it's also an interesting
thing to have a conversation about
because even if you go into Cairo a lot
of the downtown area was designed in the
late 19th century under French
occupation so there's a lot of colonial
influences in many Egyptian buildings
and architecture in general is something
of a conversation between different
cultures the architecture of minarets
specifically was inspired by church
towers and it started leading its own
life in Islamic architecture but really
no architectural style exists in a
vacuum and many of them
Implement things from each other and
take inspiration from different cultures
which I think is what makes architecture
very interesting and especially in a
theme park setting I think uh at least
for me at least it's a lot of fun to
just play around with different styles
and try to mix and match and make things
a little bit eclectic so I'm honestly
pretty happy with keeping it eclectic
like that but there are some things that
could definitely be improved on
different areas and while I'm not going
to focus on those inside certain
episodes and I'm not going to film it
because I think it takes a lot of moving
around an area and seeing what a kind of
incremental changes you can make I'm
definitely going back to some of my
older areas and seeing what things small
things I can improve like adding little
details or changing colors of certain
parts and I think it takes time and
reflection and talking with other people
to realize those kinds of things so all
that to say I'm trying my best to
balance criticism with my personal
opinion be you know everything's
subjective after all what looks good to
one person might not look good to
another but also my own motivation to
work on this stuff and the time that I
have to work on it to actually finish
this build
as as as as as as goodly as possible I
couldn't come up with a different word
so while I really appreciate all of the
constructive criticism and all of the
comments that everybody leaves on my
videos it is something that I might not
always do something with but that
doesn't mean that I don't appreciate it
because I am very happy with all the
comments that I get but especially the
comments that point out something that I
didn't do right or try to correct me on
something or just give General General
tips and tricks on stuff that I can
improve so by all means keep the
comments coming uh I love them and I
read them all even if I might not
respond to them all
anyway that's it for this episode I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
I hope to see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]